yes save me some we're keeping the party
going over here for anyone who has been
to allegiant stadium or seen a raiders
game on tv you can't help but notice the
winfield club because in true vegas
fashion we elevate every entertaining
experience and here to tell us all about
the winfield club is the general manager
hunter beatty hunter thank you for being
here thank you for having me appreciate
it so i have admired the field club from
afar i unfortunately haven't been inside
yet but it looks beautiful tell us what
you can expect when you walk in the
doors yeah we got to get you out of
there one of the times yeah but um what
you can expect is like a win experience
so basically win field club is us taking
a nightlife venue from our casino and
placing it in the north end zone of the
legion stadium
everybody who comes is shocked by how
big it is it spans the entire north end
zone and it's just a great environment
to upbeat music
djs great food from our win culinary
team along with obviously all the events
with the raider games and stuff like
that yeah and i was just asking are you
ready for the big weekend and at this
point it's like what big weekend every
weekend there's something fun going on
let's talk about the pro bowl and that's
really the place if you want to live it
up let's talk about what you guys are
doing for that yeah obviously we're open
for the pro bowl we're very excited that
it's going to be here in vegas obviously
it's been some time in hawaii in orlando
and we're hoping that vegas is the new
home of the pro bowl but it should be a
great experience for people in field
club with that upbeat energy that we
have along with the pro bowl just given
that people are there to see their
favorite players and the fact that when
field club is that field level and you
can see those people up up close and
personal and you know who knows get a
high five pound fists or anything like
that so people should be really excited
the uh the atmosphere that we're gonna
create is gonna be great and obviously
the pro bowl is something special to
come to town yeah absolutely and it
always looks like a party in the field
club and in addition to the sports side
of it can you go in the club for say a
concert or any event yeah great question
so we're open for basically every event
that happens inside of allegion stadium
so upcoming we have metallica and billy
joel at the end of the month which
people are very excited about obviously
the red hot chili peppers in late august
and then hopefully some more events will
be announced here shortly for the rest
of the stadium and people to come out
and join us and you have had some big
names hanging out in that club who's
been you know through the field club
that you can you can tell us about yeah
we've had we've had the pleasure of
having a lot of people alexander
volkanovsky and jose jose aldo excuse me
have both celebrated victories with us
for greater games we've had victoria's
secret model josephine scriver chad ocho
cinco floyd mayweather reggie bush
tyga has joined us so it's been a lot of
people obviously we've had marshmallow
do the halftime performance from our
venue we had a post-game party with
diplo so it's been a laundry list of
people that have come through that are
awesome to have isn't that so cool to
think about just a few years ago we
never knew where we were going to be now
with the sports in the legion stadium
and now you know through the winfield
club you guys get to elevate the
experience it has to just be so fun to
watch and be part of yeah it's great
it's just bringing vegas to something
that's not been in vegas before with
obviously nightlife being something
that's very vegas driven and the nfl is
so nationwide and so big to kind of mix
those two worlds has been really amazing
well in vegas it's like go big or go
home you gotta do it the right way so
hunter thank you so much be sure to
check out the winfield club i know i'm
going too soon mercedes i'll send it
over to you